energy grows where energy goes whatever
you choose to place your energy it's
going to grow whether you're online as
interviewer whether you're entrepreneurs
tone your voice because your voice is
speaking of light into your future okay
I'm done I know I go overboard
I get excited hey guys welcome to
another episode of the bow show on Evan
Carmichael's Channel as you can see
we're just ramping it up it's getting
more and more exciting and today's guest
oh I'm so excited for this one because
this started not just my journey but
millions of people's journey into
becoming the best version of themselves
I'm here today with a lot of you will
know from the secret she's the founder
of motivating the masses it's Lisa
Nichols how are you I am wonderful thank
you so much both for having me I'm super
excited to be with you today on this
channel you have all the love so many
people love it and it's very strange
you're probably twelve thousand miles
away but the influence that you've had
on my life even before the secret just
you as your story is engaging and how
you transformed yourself to become this
transformational machine that's just
changing millions of people's lives it's
so inspiring so that's why we love you
on this channel I'm grateful you know I
I could not have imagined 20 years ago
that this would be the journey and all I
kept doing but was getting out of my own
way every time it got bigger than I
thought it would ever get and my chatter
would kick in I go thank you so much but
let's get out of the way so I'm grateful
I look at my life today and I have a bit
of off and tons and tons and tons of
gratitude because as connected as you
feel to me I feel that way to you it's
this realizing that this is oneness and
if you come from things from a place of
love and gratitude and appreciation the
world is open for you yeah and I think
that's why people love you so much
because people fell in love with you I
know a lot of people who've no idea
about self development and lore
attraction stuff I gave them a copy the
secret and all of them had the same
thing they fell in love with you because
you have a heart that's bigger than the
world and what's so exciting about that
is
as you've gone on in your journey we've
seen that kind of evolve into something
bigger and I remember there was a phrase
you said a while ago that life gives you
gifts in sandpaper yes and I I just
lived by because I'm four I've had
unfortunately fortunately I've had
events in my life they've just knocked
me down and I didn't think I could get
up and when everything was against me as
soon as I realize these are gifts
I get to read get reborn in this yeah
for now yeah so one thing that a lot of
people in this channel have is their own
self-worth because they're downtrodden
because they don't feel that they're
worth anything
it's really hard for them to even start
into this journey so I just I would love
for you to let the people know let the
importance of realizing your own
self-worth and how what a miracle we
actually are if you think about love
relationships and successful careers and
a healthy lifestyle and good relays with
your children or with your family if you
think of those things as their the tree
self-worth your self-worth then becomes
the soil so everything great grows from
good soil and good soil is self worth
and self worth is something that that no
one can give us we can't go by
it doesn't start perfect and it doesn't
stay perfect self-worth is something
that's fluid it's organic it's
ever-growing so one of the things I love
to remind people is self-worth is not a
landing place because you can totally be
into a powerful sense of I'm worthy I
got it I'm in power in 2015 and then
2018 happens and you got to go back and
do it all again
so self-worth is an organic organism
it's always moving because it's
influenced by your circumstances and so
I always tell my students be mindful
that you're not measuring your
self-worth today based on something that
happened in 2006 and that's where a lot
of us are challenging we look at
ourselves worth but we do all the
experiences we've ever had in our life
and that all equals our self-worth your
experiences don't
equal your self-worth your self-worth is
influencing your future experiences and
so that's been something that I've had
to constantly look at constantly be
aware of to go wait a minute I am worthy
of love and to keep saying that I am
worthy of happiness I am worthy of joy I
am worthy of prosperity and to detach it
from what's happened in the past see we
have a tendency to determine our future
Worth based on our past experience those
are not equal those are not equal your
past experiences you do not determine
your self-worth or your work your Worth
and your value it it is what it is
because you were born it is it's never
negotiable now what you accept is
another story my father took me on my
first date when I was 12 years old and
he ordered my dinner for me and he order
my first drink from the bar I had a
Shirley Temple and he was just a total
gentleman and opened the door for me
pulled out the chair and it was so
exciting and at the end of the night Bo
as we walked into the house he opened
the door for me and right as I begin to
step through the door he closed it in
front of me and he said Lisa I took you
on your first date so that you get to
see how you get to be treated now how
you choose to be treated it's completely
on you now that did everything from me
well 15 years later 10 years later I
would be on a date and the date wasn't
necessarily honoring me the way I
thought I should be honored because I
had an example your self-worth is like
that your self-worth says here's how you
get to be treated here's the love you
get to have now what you choose is on
you but here's what you get and
self-worth is something that's
non-negotiable but guarantee fo it will
navigate how you accept love how you
expect love how you honor you the jobs
you take the relationships you let's
exist the way you walk with your head up
and so once you realize that no one else
has to do anything for you to you they
don't have to like you on Facebook
your self-worth literally sets the tone
of everything else nothing else sets the
tone ik there's a word a lot of times we
let the the experiences and a lot I've
determined ourselves work it's the other
way around your self-worth determines
the experiences that are happening in
your life so many things I hear about
that it's the insight world is the
reflection of the outside it's not only
the reflection it's influencing it's
actually influencing the way you show up
in the world with the expectations you
have on the world as the world relates
to you it's how the world will actually
respond when I was on Oprah in 2007 I
said Oprah I finally realized that the
world is looking at me first to see how
I expect to be loved honor and
appreciate it and I'm given the world
the first example of how they're to love
and appreciate me and the reality is a
lot of times we're not giving the world
the best example of how we want to be
loved
honored and appreciate it guys you're
watching this just you gotta listen to
that again there's so much in that it's
powerful I feel I got goosebumps don't
if you can see but another great thing
which I don't want to be the Lisa
Nichols quote book but a lot of what you
said throughout your years to stuck with
me I don't know why another one that
changed me overnight nearly was I had to
learn to fall in love with the darkest
parts of my life the bits where I judged
myself I was shameful I was guilty as
soon as I did that I realized I had no
kind of soft underbelly to be poked at
by any predator you changed it that's
good stuff right there you walk away I
tell people don't hold on to everything
I say just hold on to the Nuggets that
would be life-changing and if you can
fall madly in love with your the largest
part of your imperfection the largest
part of your dysfunction if you can fall
in love with what you called your worst
decisions if you can tell love and honor
and have expanded compassion for the
things that you know like you know like
you know didn't necessarily serve you
then everything else then the life will
take care of itself
see we celebrate the light and we try to
discard
darkness no no go to the darkness love
the darkness love those ding dong
moments love those moments of insecurity
love the imperfection because when you
can love the imperfection you give the
the beauty you give the beauty you give
the brilliance permission to shine
brighter it's not our brilliance that
frightens us it's the darkness that that
really isn't dark I tell people listen
if you don't keep a skeleton in the
closet then it's not a skeleton it's not
a skeleton and if you don't try to hide
your imperfection then you're not
worried about being found out or being
discovered if you don't try to mask your
dysfunction then when your dysfunction
shows up you can dance with it better I
think what you ideally loved about me
and I'm grateful to say that I think
what so many people are drawn to about
me is that I've never professed to be
perfect I simply learn how to perfectly
manage my imperfection and I think what
the public is attracted to is that I
serve you I serve you up my imperfection
ago now what do we make with this what
what what beautiful what beautiful dance
can we do with this listen just like the
next person I get worried I get doubtful
I get fearful what I do with it is
different and so it's in embracing it
sanam not only just embracing but
learning how to use your fear as fuel
your breakdowns for breakthroughs your
valleys to come out if your valley is
deep if your valley is deep and dark
then that means your mountaintop is
bright and high and if you can use that
valley as a catalyst as a catalyst to
the to the mountaintop and I don't say
that just sound cliche is sort of sound
like a preacher or anything but I say it
to say when you're on life support in
the hospital there's this there there's
that machine and that machine is doing
this right and everyone's praying for
that machine to keep doing this because
the moment Bou that machine does this
we're all in trouble and so if you treat
your life like hold on there's a value
in this there's a value in that that I
need
Valley to enjoy the peace I need both of
those things that when you begin to try
to not outrun your issues to try to not
mass to try to not protect prove or
defend and you can just be with be with
the dysfunction while you're on your way
to excellence be with the dark as you're
on your way to life because the moment
you let one live the dark the chaos the
dysfunction you actually let the light
the possibility the prosperity and the
beauty to live they they operate in a
dance when you let one live you let the
other live when you let failure exist
then you let freedom exist when you give
yourself permission to fall you actually
give yourself permission to fly they
dance together it's it's it's it's yin
yang it's dark light it's cool hot it's
all of that we're so steady trying to
show on social media and in our lives
only the perfected part of us that this
other piece actually has a sense and an
opportunity to fester grow and have a
greater power of us when you allow them
to dance
see you love my life cuz I've shared my
darkness you you embrace my beauty
because I share with you my ugly you you
see my inspiration cuz you seen my
struggle it's in the it's in the balance
and the harmony evoke that you love all
of it it's the unconscious thing that's
happening inside my life all the time
people fall in love with me more when
they hear the darkness and then they
really celebrate the light that's why
we're here right now because you got wow
she's gone through some things but if I
never allow that to exist
you can never love all of me and people
want to love all of you they love that
it's not the story of the underdog it's
that seeing someone triumph over
something and that's why so many people
I feel are a starting to use their fear
as fuel and it's becoming a wider
movement this vulnerability movement is
singing among everyone and going I I
know in my life I had a very kind of
traumatic downfall and I moved country I
just wanted to get away from it
everywhere oh when I feared someone
would might know who I was and the
morning
the bigger it got and the day I can't
turn to it and looked it in the eye and
said what are you gonna do next thing no
one cared no one gave it their right
energy grows where energy goes whatever
you choose to place your energy it's
going to grow you know that that you
place energy on is going to expand and
so the opportunity to have an authentic
experience the opportunity to be
transparent the opportunity to allow
yourself to show up and and and fully
express who you are today and the fact
that you're growing the fact that you're
evolving the fact that I'm not the man I
was five years ago and I'm not going to
be the woman I am five years from now I
am an evolving process I'm an evolving
creature I am unique and I'm full of
imperfection and breakdowns but I'm also
full of brilliance and possibility I am
full of them both and I allow myself to
experience them both in that that's
where our freedom lives it's when you're
only pursuing one thing that's your
truly captive if you're only pursuing I
don't ever plan to fail ever ever I
don't ever plan to fail but boy I give
myself permission to fail on my way to
possibility I give myself permission I
don't plan to fall but I give myself
permission to fall as I leap to fly see
because if I didn't give myself
permission to fall then I'll never jump
off the edge cuz I'm so afraid of
falling
you see people all the time they're
right on the edge and they're oh that's
because they're afraid of falling see I
plan to fly but I'm okay if I fall
because and when you become comfortable
with your ability to get back up when
people ask me what's the difference
between me and most I'm comfortable with
my bounce back I'm not afraid of being
knocked down or not and I'm not saying
I'm fearless I am saying I dance with my
fear comfortably but when you get
comfortable with your bounce back look
at all the things you've bounced back
from look at all the things you've
bounced back from if you begin to take
score and keep track on what you've
bounced back from then you'll realize
you're stronger than you ever thought
Jorma you have
resiliency that you've never even
accessed you have more perseverance and
you've not even acknowledged when you
look at your bounce-back muscle and once
you do that and all of a sudden you can
go hold on
I can play as big as out I want to play
because I'm always gonna bounce back
that's in my nature the human spirit is
designed to get back up the human spirit
is designed to soar the human spirit is
not available to the economy to the
politics Susan who's an office who's in
a relationship your human spirit is not
daunted by what's happening outside of
you your human spirit is unbreakable
it's unsay Keable and it's unstoppable
and it is always waiting on its next
command if you just live in that knowing
and you know everywhere you go your
human spirit is right there with you
your ride-or-die
besides you then you go okay come on
bring it on bring it on okay see I had
this question I was gonna ask you but
you've answered it in the most beautiful
way and I'll just recap it anyway
because life's not just about business
it's not just about life it's the whole
experience and something a lot of people
we see on this channel and in kind of
entrepreneur seekers a lot of them go
the business world whatever they're
getting into is a scary place and a lot
of some people said okay well if you do
speak to Lisa could you ask her from an
entrepreneurial point of view what would
you do if you had self-doubt I think you
just answered it you answered it all
yeah yeah listen listen hold that fear
in your hand and go yeah it's right here
I'm scared as heck I'm scared as all
get-out but then don't forget to hold
your courage on the other hand and your
resiliency so hold the fear be with the
fear but remember that fear is feeding
you fear isn't your enemy fears it
emotion like any other emotion fears
just like compassion it's like love
it's like empathy it's an emotion it's
just the meaning we gain fear that has a
tendency to stop us so fear is gonna be
present like empathy like compassion
like love like joy it's like any other
emotion but it's not designed to stop
you fear is informing you doubt is
informing you it's saying go get more
information it's saying go get a coach
it's saying stay up a little later
get up a little earlier it's informing
you look for what fear is telling you
versus just letting fear stop you and so
I do the majority of things I do now
with a little slither of fear because I
said good ain't making you nervous
you're not playing big enough listen if
everything you're doing is within your
realm of oh yeah I got this
you're not playing big enough you're
complacent so I'm always on the other
side of my comfort zone and my
grandmother says your conviction and
your convenience don't live on the same
block so if you're convicted about
something both you're gonna be
inconvenienced at some level whether
it's the discomfort of doubt the
discomfort of not having all the answers
as an entrepreneur I live on the edge
you live when you sign up to be an
entrepreneur you say excuse me hello
let me shel continuity and consistency
every day is gonna look different
uh let me she'll security and
consistency
let me put all that on the shelf and let
me sign up for this radical world that
I'm creating on the spot this climate
that will change faster than the weather
you know you're signing up for that and
so when you sign up for that you go
listen I'm willing to be mildly to
moderately to significantly
inconvenience for my passion so you got
a sign up people think that they can
play bigger than ever they've ever
played before without being
inconvenienced without being living in
discomfort everything you want is on the
other side of your comfort zone so if
you want to be comfortable man take a
step out of this game but if you want to
have make a difference in the world then
sign up to be mildly to moderately to
significantly uncomfortable and then be
willing to expand until the discomfort
becomes comfortable see the woman I am
today is not the woman I was 15 years
ago I've constantly expanded to embody
the discomfort until the discomfort
became comfortable to me and then guess
what there was a next level of
discomfort that came after that and then
I'm constantly expanding so when you're
willing as an entrepreneur to say I'm
willing to get out of my own way I'm
willing to say the things I've never
said before do the things I've never
done before as for helping away
never asked before stay up later than I
stayed get up early enough stage make
the scissors on there's maybe four
because for the man or the woman that
I'm becoming be more invested and who
you're becoming then who you been even
than who you are today I'm chasing the
2022 version of Lisa Nichols chase the
2022 version of yourself that means not
just in money but in the way you love in
the way you forgive and the way you have
expanded compassion for yourself in the
way you press pause in the way you the
way you are self list to others and the
way your in self care for yourself like
what does the 2022 version of you look
like what would he do what would she do
chase that person not just in business
but in every part of your life how will
he pray how will she meditate when you
do that you're now smallness you're then
smallness has to get out of the way
because I'd be doggone if you should be
doing this same thing in 2022 with the
same excuses in 2022 that you had in
2018 shame on you if that's you and so
look at that and go what who is she who
is he how am i contributing to the
planet how much philanthropy am i giving
how am i serving where is my free time
how am i loving how am i allowing myself
to be loved you should see something
you're not seeing today and that's
called cognitive dissonance and
cognitive dissonance is when the person
you declared yourself to be it's not the
person you're currently being today and
your mind goes into disruption and your
mind begins to chase the person you're
becoming and your behaviors and your
actions and your choices and in your
habits okay I'm done I know I go
overboard
I get excited oh that's even as you're
talking going that I've never heard it
said like that you're all yeah turn a
bit but to have that definite point so
what
with a 2022 version of Bobi for you guys
watching now who's the 2022 version of
you start aiming there that's so much
more exciting than just going I'm gonna
write some goals down Wow right and this
is real this is amazing and then you
break it down like well I'm ready
so I'm result-driven I built a
multi-million dollar company that
touches over 36 million people here I
have 7 best sellers I don't say that to
brag I say that to say I had to reinvent
myself a thousand times to do that
because I'm also I'm also that chick
that was on government assistance
needing help to feed my baby needing
help to put peppers on my son
I'm also the same woman that was in the
food line getting free turkey at
Thanksgiving
I'm also the woman that couldn't pay my
bills I'm also the woman that was
considered clinically depressed when my
son was three years old and prescribe
Prozac I'm that woman as well so when
you look at my life cycle I'm not saying
what I just said to you because it's a
great cliche I'm saying that to say you
in 1994 I had to see the 2018 version of
Lisa in 1994 I was in my bathroom mirror
speaking to crowds of hundreds and
thousands of people when all I could see
was Lisa in 1994 and 2002 I was in my
house saving my pennies every dime
writing myself a check every two weeks
and in the memo line that said funding
my dream and boy I wasn't even clear
what the dream was at the time and no
one else shared the dream with me as a
matter of fact my family would call me
crazy they had meetings about me they
were concerned about me the
relationships I was in the men they
wouldn't stay around because I seemed
like I was too bizarre dreaming this big
dream that no one could touch so I don't
say this to you as a motivational
speaker I say this to you as a woman who
was willing to redefine herself who was
willing to have parts of herself die
away
die away so that other parts of my 2020
version of me could be born
I I'm
woman whoo I don't recognize who I was
then based on Who I am now but I know
her I don't forget her because she was
she envisioned this woman the same way
I'm inviting you to envision that man
that woman out there it's not it's not
woo woo it's not if you can see it if
you can see him and in detail how much
money does he have in his bank account
how does he respond when someone says I
love you how does he respond when
someone betrays him
how does she show up in the morning and
give to herself first when I say both in
detail I'm not speaking universally I'm
not speaking in a universal way I'm
speaking in a detailed way what does he
feed his body on a daily basis how does
he open up to love when he's afraid I'm
being detailed your victories are in the
detailed vision the detailed thoughts
and the detail actions I knew exactly
what this woman was doing in 2005 I saw
her I saw her with you so when I see it
now I'm brought to tears because it
shows me the power of intention followed
by the power of consistent action if you
are listening to my voice understand it
is not enough to sit on the couch and
meditate it's not enough to sit
indian-style and and think about it it's
not enough to write a go down you have
to be committed to consistent action you
have to learn how to articulate which is
why I'm so committed to helping people
hone their message whether you're online
is interviewer whether you're an
entrepreneur hone your voice because
your voice is speaking life into your
future hone it and own it own it like
you've never owned it before speak life
into yourself and then speak life into
anyone in earshot speak life nothing but
life it's true if you're watching this
channel you're seeing the people we're
getting onto this show I started my own
channel for masters a year ago I knew no
one yet I knew I was going to get the
greatest minds in the world took
- it's an interview from there I didn't
know it's gonna be working with Evan and
now interview of people like yourself
and Anthony Robbins and all these huge
Titans but I I knew I didn't know how I
just need yeah yeah yeah and that's
called blind unwavering faith you have
to get blind unwavering non-negotiable
if you are listening to me now write it
down right now blind unwavering
non-negotiable because it requires all
three because something is going to
physically show it up always always to
challenge your dream
look at this man behind me something
showed up a thousand times to challenge
his dream in his attention 27 years in
prison to challenge his intention see
your things show up to challenge your
intention not to stop you but to
convince you what you stand for it see
every time something has showed up to
challenge my dream
it made me it made me sink deeper in my
intention and my conviction and so faith
blind unwavering non-negotiable faith is
that I know like I know like I know like
I know muscle saying I'm not looking I
don't need physical evidence in front of
me to confirm what I know in my head in
my heart I know it my head and my heart
is telling me and I'm gonna produce the
physical evidence see people do it
backwards both they look for physical
evidence as well as they look for other
people to buy into their dream and when
someone else doesn't buy into your dream
all of a sudden you let your dream wane
don't rob us of your dream see your your
f your faith your unwavering know like I
know like I know muscle has to be so
strong that you become convincing to the
world around you I remember telling
people I'm gonna inspire people all
around the world I'm gonna check all
around the world and I'm inspire people
and I remember someone saying how are
you gonna do that Lisa you got a d-minus
in speech the one time I took a speech
class I not only got a d-minus in speech
but my speech teacher said quote unquote
mrs. Nicholls I recommend that you get a
desk job and never speak in public
quote-unquote and so for fur maybe about
15 years I didn't speak in public cuz I
respected the authority in my life which
is my speech teacher then the burning in
my belly you know that burning in your
belly it that burning in your belly
doesn't go away it doesn't go away you
can try to rationalize it
you can try to minimize it you can try
to negotiate with it but that burning in
your belly is telling you what you've
been called here to do now the way you
do it might change from what you thought
but what you're supposed to do that's
not gonna go away there's a purpose on
your life is a purpose on all of our
lives and so I remember just trying to
negotiate what speaking like I'm not
supposed to be and that's what the
teacher the teacher told me I'm not
supposed to speak and the burning never
went away it never went away bo and I I
tried to out run it out negotiate it and
so I tell you that when you know like
you know like you know it might take you
longer you might have to change
directions a bit you might have to
change partners a couple of times one
time a few times you might have to slow
down but it doesn't change the fact that
what you've been put here to do is your
assignment and if you could just anchor
down and you live parked and fluid and
flexible while you become non-negotiable
and you tap into your resiliency muscle
here's what I found out it never ever
has happened to me and for me fast it's
always required more takin me more time
cost me more money took more took more
energy than I ever thought but if you
sign up for the marathon not the Sprint
you'll be okay you want it inspired life
you've lived it it's not only what
you've done inspired millions of people
you're continuing to evolve and I don't
think just me but I think everyone
listening wants to know what are you
doing now what's the next looking to
Lisa Nick what what's coming out or what
can we find you I love that question
because - a year and a half ago I went
to Barcelona
and I spent 30 days there just turning
inward just looking at my life going
I've 5x my dreams I 5x my dreams
so I was going God how do I dream how do
I keep dreaming I 5x my dreams what do I
do now how do I be of service I have one
question all the time though how can I
be of service that's all I want I want
my life to be a life that was a catalyst
to many other lives then your legacy
your legacy is far bigger than you I'm
not living from my life I'm living my
living legacy right now and I don't want
to live my legacy when I die I want to
live my legacy right here I want to see
my contribution I want to see the fruits
of my labors I want to know that they've
been seeds planted that's gonna grow a
bountiful harvest that I helped to plant
or that I helped to water I want to know
that the - the - between my birthday and
my transition day that - did a damn
thing that - did something big that -
did more than what any of us ever
imagined and not for my ego or my she go
ladies but for my sense of servant
leadership so what I've learned because
so many people have told me is that you
help us find our voice you help us use
our voice you help us discover our voice
and you help us help us craft our voice
on our message and so I've been hearing
that for 10 years ago and I don't know
why I resisted that I think I resisted
it because it's so easy for me to do
that and I came from a mindset that in
order to do something well it has to be
hard
you gotta suffer and I realized I don't
so in this season I'm helping people
really hone their voice as a
entrepreneur as a change agent as a
leader and as a speaker so I'm doing
many things but what I'm really focused
on like you'll see in the next three
years 90% of my effort
and the legacy I'll leave as I help
people craft their message
I help people craft their voice I help
people find their voice and so I'm doing
this this free you know just people go
to it and they they ideally give value
it's from good to unforgettable and when
they go there I just teach people how to
master the art of their voice how do you
use it to be a catalyst for your life
and for others and how do you make an
impact with your voice so everything I'm
doing all roads all roads lead to speak
get more powerfully as a teacher as a
minister as a speaker as an entrepreneur
as a student how do you go from good to
unforgettable where can people find that
is it on your website yeah they go to
WWE from good to unforgettable calm
they'll be able to just sign up and be
with me
well I'm in a webinar that I'm doing and
and they're nuggets that you can walk
away with instantly if you don't ever do
anything else on my campus you take it
and you can apply it instantly on how do
you hone your voice in whatever capacity
you want to use it and then if you
choose to take a further journey I deep
dive into the things that I didn't even
know I was doing that was attracting
people to me like you all over the world
I didn't know what I was doing and so I
share the unconscious brilliance that
Devine had given me when I made it a
conscious brilliance and so many of us
have an unconscious brilliance that when
we make take it from the unconscious to
the conscious it's like putting a turbo
boost on everything we touch and I want
to help turbo boost the good people in
the world who are doing good things in
the world well I know I'm gonna be there
because if I've taken away so much from
you over the last few years and that's
just indirectly what nuggets of gold and
platinum are gonna get if I actually
deep dive into work yeah so that's so
exciting
and let me tell you where where I am to
summarize it is I realize that in this
season of my life my calling my purpose
is to help as many change agents as you
like you to be more powerful more
effective and work well I'm grateful at
my impact but now my my charge is to
help change agents so I want to spend
the rest of my days touching as many
people as possible who are up to big
things in the world I don't need to
touch more people directly I want to
touch the people who are touching does
that make sense yeah I want to folks you
I want to be your secret sauce I want to
help show you how to save yourself time
and money and energy and effort that's
my assignment now is to help people who
are helping people so I'm grateful I'm
grateful listen hook your caboose onto
my train take your vitamin coming take
your vitamins hydrate and get to sleep
cause you know I'm a freight train right
that way
well Lisa thank this has just been
incredible interview because my state
has changed from the start to bubbly and
really excited to this I just feel very
grounded and I feel very I've made the
right decisions in my life and that's a
lovely transition to have in this half
an hour so what are the last things
which we ask all our guests which is
really exciting evans big thing is his
one word evans word is believed for me
it's incredible i do incredible things
I'm around incredible people like
yourself I live an incredible life is
there a word that you have that you feel
embodies Lisa it would be non-negotiable
was a heavy hitter I love it
non-negotiable faith non-negotiable love
non-negotiable forgiveness
non-negotiable resiliency it's beautiful
what a way to end this interview guys
take that away with you Lisa thank you
so so much for joining us today this has
been such an incredible journey for all
of us on the bow show guys keep watching
it again get a pen and paper out there's
so much gold in this if your life's not
changed halfway through this interview
like I know a lot of yous has and you've
already started businesses because
you've got no more fear
you're gonna change by the end of it so
Lisa thank you so much of any last words
for the guys before we go remember
you're never alone that you're never
alone that there are those of us out
here as gladiators as unicorns who are
spiritually emotionally and physically
walking beside you I'm your sister
friend and prosperity and impossibility
and I mean it when I say that I believe
in you and I love you I mean that thank
you Lisa
guys we'll see you for another bow show
soon have a great day guys
now terrific world domination
honey Empire right I'm grateful I
understand why I'm here I think because
I am so open I wanted to think and see
it's a bloody brief life all of you have
the potential for enormous success if
you want to know what garyvee DJ khalid
oprah and others know about empire
building that most people miss check out
the link in the description for a free
bonus video